welcome back to the rich eisen show
always love my chats with this gent
uh i enjoyed chatting with him offline
if you will earlier this week
i feel like we went to summer camp
together he sounds like him
he sounds like friends that i've known
for a very very long time which is
one of the reasons why i love having
them on uh the 35
ventures network is launching two
podcasts the boardroom out of office
podcast hosted by this
next guest which is available right now
and the etc with the kevin durant
podcast hosted by kevin durant and the
co-founder of 35 ventures and kevin
durant's business partner partner rich
kleiman back here on the program how are
you richard
i am well thank you richard how are you
doing very well
i am good it did do your folks call you
richard
did they do that did was that a way you
were you were growing up when you
were you were my mother say it again
yeah my mother and father call me
richard and anybody that knew me before
i was 14
but you could call me richard you know
what i always knew i was in trouble
i always knew i was in trouble when my
parents used my full name that's the
thing that i always knew i was in
trouble when i was called richard i'm
like uh oh
what did i do now you know mine was when
the ard was dropped and it became
id richard
well you know what like i said i feel
like we grew up in the same uh same
neighborhood um
so what's uh what's going on with the
what do you think of the bubble right
now it seems to be a phenomenal idea
that uh you know at the time when it was
born
uh filled with uh what-ifs and
possibilities but right now
i don't wanna i don't wanna you know uh
i guess jinx anything but it looks
amazing to me what's what about you
richard yeah i mean i think i think that
they've kind of set the gold standard
now for like
return to play literally and
figuratively you know
obviously i don't think every
institution can afford
what the nba has been able to do in
terms of the infrastructure around the
bubble but
clearly that's the way right now to
operate and function as a league
and that's the only way it seems like it
can work right now
it does seem the only way that it can
work right now and i kind of just want
to flash forward a little bit with you
too
and and uh get pull on some of your
knowledge here because obviously
you know your guy kd we're all looking
for the
2020 2021 season adam silver
uh told rachel nicholls last night that
um
there when asked if december 1st could
be a possible restart date
for the league and uh his response was
uh that might be too early because we're
targeting
our season next to include fans in the
arena what do you think about all this
um well i guess two separate things i
think pushing the start of the season
back
to me it was always uh a kind of fluid
date i think they were clear about that
from the beginning it does
probably seem a bit close especially for
some of these guys that didn't go deep
in the playoffs and also just like
taking your learnings after orlando and
then figuring out how are we going to
institute this and do this in either
different regions or
how we're going to do this next year and
if they end up doing it
in bubbles with fans or if they end up
doing it in home markets either way i
think that they're still so far from
making that decision so
it seems realistic to me that at least
in the foreseeable future that
the next few mba seasons the schedule
could be
you know a bit different than we've
we're used to seeing are a lot different
and
i it's okay you know i think it's okay
and in terms of kevin
you know i know what you were asking and
it's a real question you know if you
look at
let's say the league comes back in like
february march and then kevin would have
been out almost two full years well the
way i look at it is
age-wise i believe and circumstances
though different the timing would be the
same and
michael jordan left for a year and a
half came back in march that next year
you know and
he clearly had an incredible second run
um
a lot of people would say even better in
in some ways he was smarter
he was more efficient he was playing
angles he became a more well-rounded
player so for me i see
you know this next stage of kevin's
career whenever it comes back is really
benefiting
um and finding like the blessings and
this time off i really do think that
yeah what is what what i mean obviously
coming back right now in a bubble
and restarting up this way um
it makes sense to just say you know what
this is that season is
is toast and let's figure out the future
uh
could he play right now i mean if if if
it was absolutely
totally one thousand percent necessary
what where is he in his rehab
best you can express to us rich to be
honest with you
i honestly can't even answer that
question because it's like the kind of
thing where
you know he's just constantly working
and he's constantly working on his game
and his body
the way all players do in the offseason
he just has a prolonged offseason now
he isn't necessarily in rehab he's just
training
but you don't like i didn't even get to
ask that question because if i knew he
wasn't coming back there was no like
okay how are we ramping up could you
play
it was just the decision was made early
it was the best thing for
for him and the long-term future for the
net so you know i can't it's not as
simple to answer that question but i
mean
he's he's hooping people have seen
videos out there and
you know there's not not many cases
where he gets on the court he's not the
best player in the world
rich climbing here on the rich eisen
show uh
are you concerned about the nba business
everyone's talking about ratings i'm
thrilled to see it back
i don't care uh you know about ratings
but i'm also not
uh you know invested uh other than just
as a fan
what what do you think about the uh
future and
and people watching in the bubble and
when it comes back and how it comes back
what do you think about the future of
the nba rich
oh my god the future of the nba is as
bright as ever the
the stars in the nba are not nba stars
these are our country's biggest stars i
mean lebron is
as big a figure in the entire world the
the superstars in the nba are global
recognized names
um and our commissioner the commissioner
of the league is as good a leader as we
have in
in any business in our country so you
know i'm with you
i don't care about the ratings you know
with the middle of august
and we all just are overcoming like a
pandemic that we're still living in
and our country divided between right
and wrong and
so much in flux that if ratings are down
like so be it but the brand of the mba
has never been more powerful i i think
that and i see it in
companies that we look at i see it in
ancillary business around the nba in
sport
i see it in the amount of content and
media companies that are being created
you just see it's like
it's non-stop so no i think the nbc nba
is in great shape i mean i think
the only sport is truly
struggling now in terms of brand and
operation reputation and just interest
is clearly baseball you know even mls i
think captured newer fans during this
short period of time ratings or no
ratings
yeah so um when you say you're hearing
it and seeing a business that you're
talking to obviously with 35 ventures
and you're growing the brand of your
of durance and yourself and what you're
what you're putting together what do you
mean by that when you're
with the nba just people just obviously
you've got a remarkable client and
you've got a remarkable
um platform that you're building so
do you think it's it's the league in
general uh or is it just what you're
you're seeing for what you're building
with kd here rich
well no i mean i think obviously you
know we
we've been building a business for a
while yeah and when i'm fortunate enough
to be able to work with
somebody of kevin's caliber he's such a
force behind everything we do
and and you know and those are rare
exceptions those top players however in
general
the business of the nba in my opinion
and the amount of conversation around
the nba i mean it truly is pop culture
you see this new players tv being
launched you see
the amount of players that have media
networks and players trooping you see
your new deal with peacock
congratulations to all of you guys thank
you sir it is
as commercial and mainstream has ever
been for before
you know so that's why i'm happy that
like og's like you who have been doing
this be
when you have to struggle to do it are
getting rewarded with the deal you got
because you're still the best in the
game but the truth is is the
conversation about sports is on
every platform every medium so and i
think ratings are probably
just a bit more saturated across
different platforms but you know like
you said i don't get into ratings i like
to feel like the effect of it i mean
when the ratings affect me then i get
into it but in general i'm watching the
bubble so
i'm enjoying it me too you know and
you're you know just to i guess get in
the business aspect of this thing too i
mean
the streaming world i'm not just saying
this because peacock
you know and and my show have hooked up
this is the way it's going i mean this
is the this is the way of the world this
is the
we're already seeing there's an nfl
playoff game that's going to be on
peacock we're seeing
you know uh premier league games are
going to be put on peacock and that's
just
you know i'm just talking about peacock
alone i wouldn't be surprised if nba
games start getting streamed with
considerable
uh considerable nature and i'm sure
you're
you're you're you must be out there
talking about putting tv shows together
for kd yourself and
and the rest of your ventures on
streamers left right up and down
right now yeah well i think the most
powerful and um richest companies in
in the world in our country with the
biggest balance sheets
are companies that could like the drop
of a dime
you know play become major players in
these in these streaming deals and i
think this is an interesting time
to add to so many layers of what's going
on in sports and around the world
is that a lot of these media deals will
be up in the next few years
the world and the way in which we
consume sports and the 10 games clearly
has changed for the short term
so i think a lot of these players now
will be in in in the game to getting
um to getting rights and having carve
outs and
you know but at the same time the
broadcast networks they want to stay
around and the companies
that have lived off live tv and
meteorites they still need to be players
and they still have big balance sheets
too but
you know i think in terms of our
content and our business i think just
the fact that like we built this brand
the board room
and the idea was to have a very kind of
niche conversation about
the world of sports business and the
players that are involved from
the tech ceos to the uh sneaker
companies to
the film studios and to the athletes and
the managers and
because people can never get enough
conversation
about sports and what these athletes are
doing off the court and off the field
and what they're doing philanthropically
we were able to really turn this into a
true platform and true brand and that
just goes to show you that we started
with a niche subject and now we have
you know podcast network around it and
video distribution
broadcast distribution newsletter and
you know and and again
we are doing this and building this in a
very methodical way and
uh making it a part of our overall
business but you just see that people
are truly consuming this conversation
you know and i think some of our like
most astute business
minds and leaders in general now are
from the sports world i interviewed doc
rivers on
uh the second podcast i did for my
podcast
and you know i'm learning this as we go
and i he's impossible not to have a
great
conversation with but you realize when
you're speaking to him that these voices
are like some of the more calming
leaders of our entire country at times
well i mean for sure it's it's true
though
i mean look let's be honest rich i mean
this country you know when we shut down
um the the reason why i think a lot of
people began to
understand the seriousness of shutting
down even though it would
affect our economy and it still has
right is when rudy gobert tested
positive for coronavirus
and the ivy league says we're not going
to play um our
our conference tournament and march
madness got cancelled i mean sports
literally led the way
when sports shut down that's i know
that's the way it worked it's
my remember my wife's issues like this
is insane rudy gobert
i'm like do you know who rudy gobert is
like no no idea but
it's just like for like 24 hours rudy
gobert was like a symbol of the world
shutting down
i know and you know and you know who
scored the first bucket in the bubble
rich
right do you know who was who would he
go
damn straight it was the jazz played it
was yes he scored
he scored utah jazz played in the first
game in the bubble
and he scored the first points so he
shut down the nba in a way and then he
started it back up again i mean you
can't make that stuff up
that actually happened for sure seven
foot
center was both the first person to
score in the new form bubble and
to contract covid in the pandemic of
2020. that is correct
on the next on the next boardroom out of
office podcast
uh with with rich kleiman and so um you
got a soccer
pro you're now involved with the
philadelphia union pro soccer team now
huh
yes yes um kevin invested in the
philadelphia union okay
um became a partner and is learning the
sport we're all learning the sport
very exciting league to be a part of
very exciting ownership group to partner
with us
and we really align with them just
overall on what we
thought we could do to help them as a
brand and how they could bring more
awareness to the sport and to their team
what they could do in the community of
chester pennsylvania which is a lot of
similarities to where kd grew up so
you know what we do from a charity
component really fit
and was able to start to become part of
what our long-term goal is with with
chester and with philadelphia
and you know and it's something that i
think down the road whether it's in
soccer or
in another league we'd love to have a
larger ownership stake of a team and be
able to be involved in operations and be
able to see a league that's
running in a lot of ways mirror to how
the nba built themselves and
see a team in the northeast where you
know i'm from new york kevin from dc
it's really been a good fit and our
whole team is really aligned with them
and then
you know it's all very synergistic we're
able to use some of the stuff we do with
them and across our
boardroom platforms and you know tell
stories of
you know what it was like for their
coach to be um trying to motivate this
team and this group of players in the
bubble in orlando for mls return how it
affects the sport and the business of
soccer so
um you know it's played great into
everything else we're doing but it's
pretty exciting it's been a cool
investment for us
i bet rich well it's uh you know uh
congrats on all of that stuff i
appreciate you saying what you said
about this show you're one of my
favorite guests to have on a talk
business the sports world and obviously
uh the future if you if you could guess
you know
crystal ball it for me the 20 20 20 21
nba season
you know obviously um we don't know what
the virus is but
what do you think do you think it is
bubbled up you think it is not you think
it's sometime maybe
this later this year earlier next what
do you think
what's your best guess right now held
fire
prediction with no information correct i
could see a hybrid of some
regional games in these regional bubble
setups
some select home games games between the
nicks and nets
games between uh lakers clippers things
like that
i could see little play in tournaments
where games count and i think the nba
is the one league that can adjust and
create
new formatting and it you know for
someone like me and i bet you're the
same way i just want 82 games in the
playoff and like we all do i want the
normalcy but i do think for the next two
years you'll see
some semblance of that put together you
know and i believe in the nba
i'm i'm the most anxious and excited
both selfishly and just because
you know i i want i'm interested in
what's going on in the world to see what
happens at the nfl you know and
i'm doing my fantasy draft in a week and
it feels like it may actually be a
fantasy
because i don't know i got to be honest
with you you know i'm i'm already
i'm i'm i'm wondering in the same thing
myself
but you know if it comes down if if
everybody all if the players
make sure their vectors at home
are taken care of i think it works i
don't know how they can do that
you know obviously with you know kids
and parents and then obviously
single guys living a single life if they
can avoid all
of those trappings and if kids are
healthy and families stay healthy
players outside of their facilities if
they take care of those vectors
i think there's a season i really do i
believe that
i agree with you i agree with you i
think first of all
some therapies are continuing to evolve
our
our kind of mindsets are changing a bit
and the nfl has the money and the access
to figure out what they need to do to
keep people safe plus we
we're numb to it a bit it's it's scary
and horrible but like i'm reading in the
post today a few mets have it
and not once am i thinking like that the
world's coming to an end or that the
mets should shut down it's just like
when are they going to return to play
and
as sad and unfortunate as that is i
think that is some of the reality now
i agree i agree and the one thing though
that the nba in the bubble
has i guess for the lack of a better
phrase test piloted
that i hope they continue i loved the
play-in for the eighth seed
whatever the heck that was i loved it
i loved it and i hope that that's they
figure out how to do something like that
and i know that
chris brockman didn't uh didn't
windhorse the vspn
say maybe have some sort of week-long
tournament eight through 15
from now on or something like that to
keep people from tanking and that
maybe some team you know some 14 seed
could catch fire or something like that
i i would love something like that from
here on out
that was great yeah i love it the whole
crew is in there nobody's talking to me
today
no i mean we just got uh we got
chris over there yeah i mean you guys
were locked in [ __ ] i didn't want to
interrupt two riches he doesn't like to
interrupt in there
you know chris you know i'm always down
to chat with you too bro well rich
rich we'll get you back on in short
order and then we'll just open it up to
we'll even take phone calls with you you
sound like one of those guys that would
take phone calls
okay do you take care be well you and
your family safe podcast
wants your honest office boardroom
network kevin's launches next month
i started with jack dorsey and doc
rivers were two podcasts in and
getting your feedback would be uh would
be a real honor i'd love to do it
by the way uh any conversation with you
and jack and obviously you and doc
like that i mean uh i'm i'm in i'm i'm
way in i'll i'll give you my thoughts on
varney check it out let me know what you
think can i have a weekend guys you got
it it's where
it's available where all podcasts can be
gotten apple spotifyradio.com
and where all podcasts are available
that is rich climate right
here on the rich eisens show follow him
at rich climate on twitter at 35
ventures at boardroom
as well that's how you can get in touch
with him
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here